you felt when those three guys were all
together they had bonded somehow that
was The White Album right
that's where you walked out of the beach
yeah well no I only went out because I
did feel like it was you know we don't
happen that was fine and we were trying
to be a band again which I love right
and then I'm look you know I'm there in
the studio and it's like I I don't feel
good I don't feel part of it so I go and
knock on John's door and I say hey
you know I just don't feel right I don't
feel that you know I'm part of this you
three seems so close and he goes I
thought it was you three right so I said
okay I'll go and knock on Paul's door
and they tell them the same thing and
you know I don't feel part of this I
feel you three are so close and he goes
I thought it was you three right so I
said it I'm off